Here's the routine. It's very short.
It goes through the measurements. It assumes it has as many motions as measurements.
It first applies the measurement as before. Then it applies the motion.
When it's done with it, it prints the output, and the output is interesting.
The world has a green, a red, a red, and a green, and a green field.
The robot saw red, followed by a right motion, and green.
That suggests that it probably started
with with the highest likelihood in grid cell number 3,
which is the right-most of the two red cells.
It saw red correctly. It then moved to the right by 1.
It saw green correctly, moved right again.
It now finds itself most likely in the right-most cell.
This is just looking at these values over here without any probabilistic math
and any code limitation.
Let's look at the output--0.2, 0.1, 0.08, 0.16, 0.38.
Very correctly, then it would most likely assign this position to the right-most cell
as should be, given the sequence of observations over here.